a friend of mine said to me like how
many times do you see your parents per
year I said you know maybe once and he
said okay so you're gonna see them 15
more times before they die I remember
hearing that and feeling like I got
punched in the gut hey friends welcome
back to Deep dive the weekly podcast
where every week it is my immense
pleasure to sit down with authors
entrepreneurs creators and other
inspiring people and we find out how
they got to where they are and the
strategies and tools we can learn from
them to help us build a life that we
love style has been one of the most
requested guests on the podcast for ages
and the reception to his first
appearance on the podcast was so strong
that when he decided to come over to
London we thought you know what let's do
a part two for the podcast so in this
episode we talk about how to systemize
life we talk about strategies and tools
for building Better Health and
relationships I'm not prideful about
trying to make progress in my
relationship so so if I can find ways if
I can find systems tools Frameworks
whatever it is that allow us to grow
over time and that allow us to find the
space to grow over time that's impactful
to me we talk a bit about Cyril's
Journey from a finance bro to a content
creator and we talk about a few life
hacks the mental health tactics that we
can use to help build a life that we
love if I am not growing in some way as
a human being that's when I'm going to
be dead
for me personally I just want to be
around people who push me to be slightly
better than I was at whatever it is
welcome back to the podcast we are
meeting in person for the first time so
great to see you how are you doing in
person is so much more magical and I am
stoked to be here with you this is gonna
be great I would love to start off with
a little bit of controversy that you've
sparked on the internet recently okay uh
on Twitter you tweeted something that
actually my girlfriend sent me
um oh that's never good
and we actually did this thing like last
night actually okay we had our first
life dinner there you go so your Tweet
said my wife and I recently started a
monthly check-in ritual it's been
incredible for a relationship of the
life dinner
um what is the life dinner and then wise
has been particularly controversial the
wives have been controversial question
is going to be an interesting discussion
so the life dinner is basically a system
for a little bit of structure in
developing your relationship over time
particularly when life gets hectic and
so I tend to think this happens a lot
for either
a couple that has both people that are
really like in kind of driven career
roles and are really pushing and running
and traveling in different directions or
after having a kid when your life
becomes infinitely more hectic because
you have you know a crazy person and a
crazy human running around and
developing so I read about this for the
first time several years ago as an
entrepreneur named Brad Feld who had
um written a blog post I think about it
and published and I had read it and sort
of just like logged it in the back of my
mind as something that was interesting
basically the idea is you set in his
version you set a single monthly date
like call it the first Monday of every
single month my wife or my partner and I
are going to sit down over a dinner at
some special place or at home make a
dinner just the two of you and really
have like a semi-structured discussion
of important things in your life like
what's the most important thing in your
professional life right now what's the
most important thing in your personal
life what are you focusing on what are
the kind of like things that are bugging
you what's the tension in your life Etc
just really have like an open thoughtful
hour plus discussion one-on-one and the
idea is that life over time becomes more
and more chaotic and you're not able to
do that and so having like a true Line
in the Sand that you're going to do this
at least once a month is a good way to
just make sure that it's happening and
continue to progress your relationship
yeah um so why was it so controversial
so I think in general relationship
advice tends to be controversial because
it's the same as like relationship
advice parenting advice political
commentary you know these things that
like
tend to be
um tend to elicit the reaction of like
don't tell me what to do I I know
everything I've already figured this out
and the funny thing to me about like why
it became controversial is I wasn't
telling everyone to do it I was simply
saying I have found this beneficial and
here's how we do it and if you find it
interesting like try it otherwise just
ignore it and that's totally fine with
me which is sort of the case with all of
my content so I'm always blown away when
I get responses that are like you're an
idiot or like you're a devil you know
you're the devil like I hope you get
divorced you know like there were people
that were replying to this like if you
have to do this you're already going to
get a divorce this isn't going to work
um which to me like I can just laugh off
because I'm beautiful and healthy and
happy marriage and I personally just
think like if you are not growing in
your relationship and you're if you're
not finding time for these discussions
um you're going to struggle and I don't
like I'm not prideful about trying to
make progress in my relationship so so
if I can find ways if I can find systems
tools Frameworks whatever it is that
allow us to grow over time and that
allow us to find the space to grow over
time that's impactful to me yeah I love
it like I'm big on systemizing
systemizing relationships I think it's
such a a big hack and one of the things
that my brother and I often talk about
is that
um a lot of gains in our personal life
can be found through treating it more
like a business and actually a lot of
gains in our business can be found
through treating it more personally and
there's like a little bit of a middle
ground because for example no one bats
an eyelid if you write down birthdays in
a calendar to remind yourself of
birthdays but that is systemizing a
relationship if you really cared would
you like you'd remember the birthday you
probably wouldn't you recognize that
like sometimes you need you need a
little bit of a reminder because I'm
gonna say that by the way about personal
crms like you know the whole idea that
no one you know there's like Salesforce
which is like a CRM tool for businesses
to like remind you of people you need to
Ping and where they are in your sales
cycle Etc and a bunch of companies have
tried to do that for personal things
like birthday reminders or like when's
the last time you spoke to so and so for
your network development and a lot of
people will push back against that
people say like oh you know you're
making it unnatural you're making it
like this automated like you're just
managing human beings and those are
humans you shouldn't do that and so it
just depends on where you sit on the
spectrum of wanting to do that or not I
actually don't care if if I give this
piece of advice and I say that this is
the life dinner is something that helps
me if it's not for you that's totally
okay like if you don't want to
systematize your relationship that's
fine and I'm not going to tell you that
I think you're going to get a divorce
because you're not doing it like I just
won't say anything it's not you know if
you have a great relationship without
doing these things I think that's
awesome if you talk to your wife tons
and you somehow with a newborn find time
to have these discussions daily you're
like a superhero in my book that's
amazing we don't do that it's very
difficult I find and so doing these
things finding these little systems I
find is just super super helpful yeah
I'm fully fully on on the same page with
you on this I've tried so many different
systems for personal crming over the
years never quite stuck to one yeah but
the thing I come back to is I actually
have a list in my Apple notes just of
people I want to stay in touch with and
the other day I was inviting some
friends over for dinner and I just I was
thinking have I have I invited everyone
I I think I've invited the people that I
I think I want to group up with this
thing and I just thought you know what
let me just consult the list and I
realized oh I actually should invite
this person but I didn't think of them
in that group because that group is uni
University friends and University
friends I lump as like a category in my
mind but this person I met sort of
outside University but he gelled with
the group so I saw his name on the list
that's a great idea messaged him and
he's coming and now he's going to meet
my meet my uni friends and just the by
virtue of the fact I have a list of
friends I want to stay in touch with it
is now encouraging those connections to
happen I did this at one point with
people in cities so once College ended
and I was no longer like with my core
group of friends in one place everyone
had moved all over the place like people
were starting jobs in different cities
different countries whatever I realized
that I needed to be deliberate when I
traveled about making sure that like if
I was in London I need to make sure that
I see my couple of friends that are in
London that I know I like really want to
see and so I made a list of like in
these big cities that I might be going
to who are the like five people that I
know in those cities and it's a reminder
for me because like LinkedIn is okay for
that you can sometimes like search who
to you know who my first year
connections but you know this at scale
LinkedIn becomes a travesty like it's a
real disaster for me at this point and
so I can't really use it for that and so
having like a little list of that like
what's my little black book of people
that I know in these different cities is
actually a you know remarkable little
hack you mentioned yeah people like this
sorry to cut you off the systematizing
uh relationships thing does really
bother some people
um and I'm just a big believer that like
systems is actually a misnomer people
when they hear systems they start to
think like oh we're becoming robots and
we're not going to have a normal
conversation and like you know when
people will read my content they're like
oh you know he must not be normal in
person because you're not able to just
like have a conversation with someone
that's not what it is to me it's like
finding little heuristics shortcuts ways
to save yourself time and energy that
make your life easier in some way that
make your life better and easier
um you know at whatever it is you're
doing and so why not have those for
relationships the same way you would for
work yeah I think it's sort of like yeah
this like for like for example
systemizing workouts if you have a list
of the exercises you're going to do I'm
going to do these exercises three times
a week and I'm just gonna follow the
plan that system that's systemizing your
health in a way that really leads to
results whereas the alternative thing of
like spontaneous spontaneity when I go
to the gym is not really going to get
anyone anywhere unless of course they
would they want to be the person that
a lot of just goes for a run when they
go to the gym or whatever they might
like I mean your natural bias as a human
being is to do the easiest thing like
our natural bias is towards sloth Dome I
always say that about myself for sure
like I'm a I consider myself an
extremely disciplined and hard-working
person but my natural bias is still to
be a sloth like if I wake up in the
morning and I don't know what my first
task is going to be of the day I end up
doing the easiest dumbest task that
doesn't actually drive anything forward
so what I had to do to systematize and
make sure that that doesn't happen is
the night before I decide what I'm going
to do the next morning and I get it set
up like if I need to work on a
particularly challenging section of my
book I'm going to open up that section
and I'm going to be zoomed in on that
section so that when I get to my desk
and open it up that's the only choice
that I have it's sitting right there and
that's just like you're creating systems
so that things get a little bit easier
for you to go and Tackle to fight that
natural tendency to just be a sloth yeah
there's a great book I read over the
weekend or listen to the audiobook of
called buy back your time
yeah yeah
um and one of the things he he is very
bullish on actually and and also
yesterday I listened to the audiobook
for lean in by Cheryl Sandberg which is
absolutely my mind like really good
um and in both those books they talk
about I think you know systemizing
relationships to some extent in lean and
Charles Hamburg talks about kind of
making sure that like she has a system
for when she's gonna go home from work
and that time where the family is
blocked out and things like that and
what Dan Martell says in the book which
I I found myself like fully agreeing
with is that the system does not reduce
spontaneous spontaneity and creativity
it actually increases it because it
means you now don't have to think about
that like I know when I have like my
date nights pre-scheduled with a
girlfriend in the calendar for the next
like three months based on our various
schedules that means that every other
evening if you're coming over I can be
like oh I've got this evening free I
don't have to think in the back of my
mind like ah I've just got to make sure
we've got like some time for the
relationship schedule that week but
because it's all pre-scheduled and it's
just like so liberating and like a
weight taken off my shoulders when I
know that we've got date night scheduled
for the next two or three months yeah I
found that once I got got more
disciplined about my time and about
blocking time for activities I all of a
sudden also had more free time within my
day for those spontaneous spawn like
that all of that spontaneity to kind of
bleed in and so like an example of that
you know Parkinson's law the idea that
work expands to fill the time allotted
for its completion I used to email all
day because I didn't have a block of
time when my email time was and so I
would literally just email like I'd pop
open email and shoot some emails off and
then I'd close it and do a little bit of
work and then pop back into email and
what happened was my entire day all of
the like liminal moments those little
like the flex time in between calls or
in between meetings or in between deep
work was email because I was just
filling it and so suddenly you like you
lose the brakes and you lose your time
for those creative interesting thoughts
that are getting sparked or you lose the
conversation you had with your wife or
the little play time with your son or
whatever it is because it's being filled
by this like sponge-like creature that
you're not naturally limiting once I
started taking advantage of Parkinson's
law and actually shrinking and forcing
the time for those activities into
little Windows creating a real system
around them that unlocked my creativity
100x I think nice what are some other
areas in which you found systemizing
helpful for like personal or
professional life phoo so many
um let's see so health for sure uh
having
I think having a set of non-negotiables
has been a system for almost everything
in my life
um you know I say health but having a
having a set of non-negotiables for your
health for your relationships for your
kind of like just daily existence for
your professional career I think is
extremely important what I mean by that
is here are the three to five things
that I must do every day to function at
my best so for me personally like on the
on the physical side
I'm a big believer that in order to show
up as a husband and as a father in the
way that I want to I have to take care
of myself physically and mentally and
that is love for those other people
around me just as much as it is love for
myself because if I'm not doing those
things I'm not the type of person that I
want to be I'm not taking care of myself
in the way that I should and I can't
show up for them and for me that means I
need to do 60 Minutes of physical
activity a day I need to get in the cold
plunge every single morning and I need
to be outside and going for a couple of
walks every single day if I do those
three things I know no matter what
everything else can go to and my
day is great in that regard and I'm able
to show up in the way that I want to so
having that set of non-negotiables like
no matter what I'm gonna do these couple
of things is really important in every
area of your life in my professional
life all I need to do to feel that I
check my non-negotiables off the list is
an hour of deep work like true deep work
focused on something that I find
meaningful if nothing else happens
during the course of the day I can just
like sit back and say okay well at least
I did that and when you have a young kid
sometimes days do just go to it
happens even before you have a kid but
it only gets worse over time and so for
me like what that means is that I'm up
early because I know that before my son
wakes up it's the time when I can
guarantee I can get that for me now it's
two and a half hours I can get that two
and a half hours in from five to seven
thirty in the morning and if he's sick
or fussy during the day or my wife needs
help or my you know family is in town
whatever it is the chaos that just
naturally happens I at least got that
period of work done my non-negotiable
was checked off the list so having that
across the different areas of your life
and for me literally writing it down and
like checking it off whether in notion
or on a piece of paper or whatever it is
has gone a long way for making sure that
I'm making progress on the things that
matter to me nice
what other
um other than the life dinner do you and
your wife or and other relationships do
you have any other systems that you
found super helpful
I try to make sure that I'm checking in
and having a conversation with one
person every single week is a big one
for me with friendships
um again like a system for making sure
that you actually keep up with the
people that matter to you in life this
isn't about networking to me I've never
been much of a networker networking was
like a big thing in the finance world
where you know where I previously was
like you had to have a big Rolodex that
was like the thing everyone said like
man he's got a great Rolodex whatever it
was I always hated the transactional
nature a Rolodex is like that
old-fashioned you should have a Rolodex
yeah it was that old-fashioned thing
that they used to have in offices that
had someone's like info information on
it or you would put their business card
in and it was literally like a spinner
so it would it was alphabetized and so
you'd like open your Rolodex and you
could go to like the bees and you would
have like saho Bloom was in there you'd
go to hey and you could have Ali abdom
like you would scroll through your
Rolodex it was like a you know it was
like a contact list clever but it was it
was physical
um and so everyone used to say like you
got to have a big Rolodex in order to
succeed in finance and I just always
hated this sort of fake transactional
nature of those kind of um those kind of
mentalities and relationships and so my
thing is there's you know maybe 20 30 40
people in your life that are friends
that you know you feel have impacted you
and will continue to over a period of
time and you want to make sure that
those friendships don't atrophy
and it's very easy to let them atrophy
and we're all guilty of that in some way
shape or form because life takes over
you just are like doing things and
stuff's happening you don't live in the
same place as the person whatever but
it's very easy to find 10 minutes when
you're out on a walk to just like text
someone or call them and just say like
hey I was thinking of you what's going
on how are things
um but if you don't have
like a forcing function to do it we just
don't you forget like life just happens
and so I'm I mean this is one of my new
things from 2023 is I'm trying to do
that at least once a week just call
someone and just say like hey what's
going on I was thinking about you what's
what's new in your life and the
challenge with calling is a lot of times
people don't pick up so sometimes it
turns into a text and then it leads to
an interesting conversation whatever it
might be just finding a reason to kind
of like Ping those people that you don't
necessarily talk to every single day and
catch up with them how do you feel about
proximity to family and friends
in what sense in the sense of
um the value of uh okay so relationships
with people that we care about always
after a few over time if left of their
own devices
um often people will move away from
their parents or move away from the
friends they grew up with and then that
just like decimates the amount of time
you get to spend with them
um
to what extent do you think it's
important to have kind of physical
proximity to people that you love as a
thing or do you think that it's broadly
taken care of through like phone calls
and visiting occasionally and that kind
of stuff
um I don't think there's any replacement
for in-person interaction with people in
terms of actually building and fostering
relationships I'm sitting here with you
because I would much rather do this in
person and do a zoom yeah I like I
literally flew to London so that I could
get to do a few of these things in
person and actually build relationships
because that's what matters to me most
in life the single greatest predictor of
Health at age 80 is relationship
satisfaction at age 50. the Harvard
study of adult development found that
longitudinal study 80 plus years that
was what they found the single greatest
predictor of Health at 80 was
relationship satisfaction of 50. what
does that mean to me it means that I
really really care deeply about building
and fostering deep relationships with
people I think there's certain breath to
it you build relationships over time but
I want to meet the people that I can go
deep with and that I can work with and
that I can love in different seasons of
my life for me that means spending time
in person with people and it's you know
when you talk about your parents that's
the first one this is the biggest life
change I've made in the last several
years my wife and I dropped our entire
life in California and moved back to the
east coast because we realized that our
parents weren't going to be around
forever
um you know both of us had grown up in
the Boston area
um my parents were you know getting into
their mid-60s and a friend of mine said
to me like how many times do you see
your parents per year I said you know
maybe once and he said okay so you're
going to see them 15 more times before
they die
and I remember hearing that and feeling
like I got punched in the gun and
the countable nature of the number of
times you are going to see someone as
close as your parents
before they die is terrifying it's
terrifying to think that you can
actually just count that on like you
know almost on two hands at that point
especially when you feel as close to
them as I did and So within 45 days of
hearing that we sold our house in
California moved back across to the east
coast and bought a house in the New York
area so that we could be closer to our
parents and now you know we have a young
kid they get to be a part of their
grandson's life they're around all the
time I see my parents you know at least
twice a month maybe more and it's an
amazing thing just getting to have those
like nothing moments where you're just
hanging out where you're just talking to
them it's like there's absolutely no
replacement for that and it's something
I will never regret as long as I live
um so with parents I think
it's really important to realize they're
just not going to be around forever
with friends I think it's a little bit
of a different story because
you have seasons to your life there's
not one you know one act to your life
play where you're the same person for
the entirety of your life nor are your
friends the same person over the
entirety of their lives and so there are
some friends who are great fit for one
season of your life and aren't going to
be there in the next one and that's okay
you don't have to keep trying to jam
them in there I have some amazing
friends from my high school year so I'm
no longer close with I think they're
lovely people they're great in their own
different ways but we're just in
different worlds now we've gone about
different paths and are doing different
things and I think that's totally fine I
think continuing to try to live with and
be around people that aren't actually a
matching that aren't developing you and
you aren't developing them is actually a
bad thing and so being aware that it's
okay to leave things behind to like shed
your old Shell and move on to the new
one like a you know hermit crab does
over the course of its life is totally
a positive thing in certain cases what
do you mean by developing like a cynic
might say that like you know the the
tech productivity Bros like you and me
would think that every relationship
needs to be developmental in some way
what about just enjoying time with your
mates from high school I just think that
enjoying time is developing like I think
if I'm if I am not growing in some way
as a human being that's when I'm going
to be dead
for me personally that's not maybe for
everyone maybe some people don't feel
that way and they don't feel like they
need to grow I just want to be around
people who push me to be slightly better
than I was at whatever it is and if
that's slightly better at being able to
let loose and have fun that's a version
of getting better for me I'm not great
at that sometimes sometimes I'm like so
wired to be in the Weeds on whatever it
is that I need to get better at that and
so I do have some friends who are really
good at letting me let loose and I
consider that to be developing in a way
they're helping me develop in a
different way in in my world and maybe
I'm helping them buckle down a little
bit more in certain areas of their life
so I don't say development in the sense
of like scoreboard and you know here
look here's how I develop here's how
this person developed me and if they
didn't help me develop in this way then
I'm going to cut them out of my life I
really say it in the holistic sense of
building a comprehensively wealthy life
like I'm not trying to be the richest
person in the world I'm by any stretch
of the imagination I'm not gunning for
that I don't want that what I want is to
have an unbelievably balanced and
fulfilling life and really spend it with
people that I care about nice
um so
coming back to the controversy of this
relationship stuff yeah um you mentioned
that when you see people responding to
your thing to saying that you're the
devil or that you're gonna wishing you
get divorced you you mentioned that you
just laugh it off yeah uh how how do you
do that because the the concern about
hate on the internet stops a lot of
people from
putting themselves out there yeah um
yeah how have you well what strategy
systems what are my systems for the hate
when I write about systems what are my
systems for dealing with the hate that
comes from the talk on systems it's very
meta
um no it all jokes aside I mean there's
a few things that I've learned from the
greats that have come before us like the
Tim ferrisses of the world and people
who have written about this in the past
um and then there's a few things that
I've I would say developed on my own I
mean one of the biggest ways is to just
avoid reading comments when you see
things taking a turn for the negative so
like with that life dinner one I saw
some of the early quote tweets and
normally like you know for people that
don't know Twitter that well once you
start seeing quote tweets ticking up
like really fast alongside retweets you
know that there's some going down
like you got it you're like ooh okay
there's something happening and for me I
was like okay I stand by this I think
this is a great idea so I actually I
don't really care it's fine like quote
tweets are actually going to drive more
people to positively see the idea and
what it led to was tons of messages from
people that are like hey this is a great
idea I tried this like you
um that are going to you know benefit
from it in some way so in any case I saw
the quotes you started to take up first
thing I did was I muted it so I muted
the conversation so that I would never
get a notification about it because for
me that's like okay out of sight out of
mind people can say whatever they want
about me fine I don't care and it was
funny like you messaged me and you were
like hey hope you're good and I was like
I'm blissfully ignorant like I'm waving
around like I have no idea what's going
on it's totally fine so that's number
one
number two is
when someone writes something mean about
you who they don't know on the internet
that person is not a happy person I've
never met someone happy who has sat down
and written something extremely negative
about a person they don't know it just
doesn't happen that person has some sort
of pain or trauma or something in their
life that is leading them to react the
way that they are to this and
the most powerful thing I've ever read
on this is like you should default to
empathy when you see someone react that
way because there's something going on
in their life I just had a conversation
with a friend who had encountered this
who said that he shot a message to the
person that had sent the negative
thought and said like hey I hope you're
I hope you're all right you know I hope
everything's fine and the person replied
and said basically sorry you know my
wife my my wife recently got diagnosed
with cancer and so the way that you were
at this thing it really rubbed me the
wrong way and that's why I reacted
negatively and he said to me like you
know what a thing because I would have
replied really negatively to his
response but instead I defaulted to
empathy and realized that there was this
really challenging moment in this
person's life so that's the second one
the third one for me is like
a little bit more of like a
I don't know Flex or a slightly arrogant
version of this which is I had a moment
maybe like this might be like six months
ago now where someone said something
really mean and negative to me on the
internet and I was like in the bathroom
I read it and I was pretty bummed I was
like man this person doesn't know me and
then they said all these mean things
about me what is this and I came back
into my room and my son was in there uh
you know my beautiful wife was in bed I
like got into bed I have this nice house
and I was sitting there and I was like
huh yeah this is okay like you know you
know like here I am this person's
probably sitting in their mom's basement
talking crap to me on the internet and
I'm like I'm life's pretty good this is
all right like I can deal with it I can
take the heat like if I if I wasn't
comfortable taking the heat I should get
out of the kitchen
um so there's a little bit of just like
the man in the arena you know the Teddy
Roosevelt thing of when you're gonna put
yourself out there and you're gonna be
on in you know in the arena and on the
arena on that stage these things are
gonna happen you're going to draw some
of it people are going to be negative
and that's okay
all right we're just going to take a
quick break from the podcast to
introduce our sponsor which is huel now
this is very exciting because I've
actually been a pain customer of huel
since 2017. I started eating kill in my
fifth year of medical school and I've
been using heel regularly ever since
because you know I like to be productive
I you know my calendar is full with a
lot of things and often I don't have the
time or don't make the time to have a
particularly healthy breakfast or a
particularly healthy lunch and heal is
fantastic for those occasions because
it's 400 calories they've got tons and
tons of different flavors my favorite
flavor is salted caramel because for
that you get 400 calories you also get
40 grams of protein super hard to get
enough protein in my diet these days
especially with trying to get hinge and
working out cure to make sure that I get
at least those 40 grams in the 400
calories and it's got 26 different
vitamins and minerals which really helps
with the whole healthy balanced diet
thing as well now I don't use heal with
every meal I wouldn't recommend using it
with every meal but in those occasions
where you find yourself reaching for a
very unhealthy snack we're about to
order a really unhealthy takeaway it's
just absolutely fantastic to be able to
have the option now I use the heel black
edition in the mornings it's very nice I
put two scoops of powder into my little
blender type thing I add water sometimes
a bit of milk and that gives me what I
need but also for lunch I like using the
huel hot and savory product they've got
which basically you add boiling water to
this container of stuff and you can make
yourself like a they've got a really
good cheese pasta type one which is
which is my favorite thing and again
also all of these are nutritionally
complete meals they're all vegan they
all have all these nutrients and
vitamins and minerals and stuff and
they're often reasonably high protein as
well and it's also ridiculously cost
effective like one of these meals is one
pound 68 for a 400 calorie meal which is
like a tenth of the price of what I
would be ordering from deliveroo instead
and so really huel is a perfect
companion for a busy life where you want
to get a lot of things done and you
don't if you don't necessarily have a
lot of time to cook a healthy meal and
deal with all the prep and all the
shopping and all the cleanup then heal
is a great addition to your life rather
than a replacement for all of the meals
in your life anyway if that sounds
appeal Street and you want to try out
heal then if you head over to heel.com
forward slash deep dive that URL is a
special URL which will give you a free
t-shirt and a free Shaker thing with
your first order and so yeah head over
to heel.com forward slash deep dive and
thank you so much Hill for sponsoring
this episode this episode is very kindly
brought to you by trading 212. now
people ask me all the time for advice
about investing because I've made a
bunch of videos about it on the YouTube
channel and my advice for most people is
generally invest in Broad stock market
index funds which is exactly what you
can do completely for free with trading
212. it's a great app that lets you
trade stocks and funds and ETFs and
foreign exchange if you really want to
and one of the great things about the
app is that if you're new to the world
of investing you can actually invest
with fake money you don't have to put
real money in they've got a practice
mode where you invest fake money and
then it actually tracks what the market
is doing in real time so you can see had
I invested 100 pounds into this thing
what would my return have been X weeks
or X months further down the line once
you've got some comfort with that then
it's super easy to deposit money into
your trading tube into account you can
use Apple pay like I do initially or you
can use a direct bank transfer and then
once the money is in your trading 212
account then you can invest it in
basically whatever you want the other
really cool feature about trading 212 is
their pies feature so what you can do is
you can follow people who've created
investing pies for example someone might
have a pie where I don't know 30 of his
apple and 20 is Tesla and 10 is the S P
500 and you can follow people on the app
and see what pies they've created and
you can see the performance of those
pies and then you can just copy and
paste a particular pie into your own
account and so that means like let's say
you've got 100 pounds to invest and
you've put 50 of it into the S P 500 but
you want to be a little bit more
experimental with the other 50 pounds
you could invest it into a pie where
someone else is generally a pro or
someone in their bedroom who just loves
the markets has already done all the
homework for you also very excitingly
there's a new feature that they've added
to the app which is a daily interest on
your uninvested cash these interest
rates may go up or down over time as the
economic environment changes but the
cool thing is that you get paid out
every single day if you're into that
sort of thing and so if you haven't yet
started when investing and you want to
give it a go then you can download the
app on the App Store and if you use the
coupon code Ali Ali at the checkout that
will give you a totally free share worth
up to 100 pounds it's available on
iPhone and Android and you can check it
out by typing in trading 212 into your
respective App Store so thank you so
much trading212 for sponsoring this
episode to what extent if any do worry
about uh posting pictures of your wife
and son on the internet I get asked this
a lot recently
um
I on a scale of
one to ten one being
uh you know Ultra controversial person
you know Donald Trump
and 10 being
flowery you know just posting pictures
of beautiful fields of flowers I'm
probably like an eight and a half like
my content is so uncontroversial on
average and positive I know and I never
attack people back I basically just take
it and whatever it is the most
controversial thing I can say is that
you should have a monthly date night
with your wife to talk about things
that's controversial for me and like I
didn't even realize that was good but
that's that's an eight for me
um
because of that I don't worry about it
as much as I otherwise would if I was
like a five
I would worry about there being angry
people that are getting mad about things
that I'm doing
you know I'm not like selling things I
don't do conferences I'm not uh you know
doing things where there's going to be
someone out there that feels like I hurt
them or scammed them all my stuff is
free you know with the exception of an
eventual book which no one has to buy if
they don't want to
um
I tend to think that at least now I
don't worry about it a lot
um but there are instances where it kind
of hits me like you know I'm in the
grocery store with my wife and son and
someone comes up and they're like oh is
that Roman you know a random person that
I've never met before that recognized me
him from Instagram or something and that
kind of makes me think where I'm like
hmm once he no longer looks like an
ambiguous baby this might not be the
best and smartest thing to do
um so
you know kind of long way of saying
I haven't really thought about the
downsides and the risk to date but
will there be downsides and risks in the
future yeah probably hmm
what about you yeah it's something I've
started increasingly thinking about
um like I'm fairly public about my
personal life well I'm fairly public
about things like my finances on the
internet so it's easy enough for people
to figure out how much money the
business owns which they then
extrapolate to how much money I am uh
how much money I own which then the
thenx practice how much money is in my
personal bank account yeah uh I don't do
that yeah I never talk about money
um you know really like I don't I don't
post too much about it because I do
think that that draw it you know there's
a plus side to it people love that kind
of transparency and they learn a lot
from it and they get inspired by it
everything is risk and you know it's
just trade-offs
um but anyway sorry continue yeah so I
do that kind of stuff and increasingly
you know now each year when I come to
making the video like I was talking to
my girlfriend about it for the 2022
video and she was saying that you know
is this is this still a good idea
and that kind of made me think that like
hmm I haven't really thought about it to
date but you're right now that like
especially if I have a wife and child
and family and stuff in the future
I mean I don't earn anywhere near as
much as like football is doing everyone
kind of knows where they live based in
London but you know London is fair is a
fairly safe City there are other places
in the world they're a lot less safe Tim
Ferriss had the blog post about reasons
not to become famous where he talked
about potentially you know getting
kidnapped at random airports and running
places that he would go to which is why
he has to use an alias and a fake name
and book hotels under a fake name
because they give they sell their data
sometimes to the kidnappers and all of
those things
uh kind of made me think huh I wonder if
I should reassess my approach to sharing
stuff online
um especially when a family gets
involved with this kind of stuff so I
was just curious I mean my um
it's a tricky question because I think
that in an era where AI will
increasingly replace the actual content
that is being created especially written
content first then video over time
personality and human connection is
really important and I personally think
that as robots and as AI becomes more
and more of our life on a daily basis
people are going to have this like
pendulum swing where they're going to
really starve for and and crave true
human interaction and so for me
I have wanted to create that depth of
connection with the people that are in
my community that are following me I
like I still reply to emails that people
send me I reply to DMS you know I have
all this stuff open even though my
audience is now probably too large to do
that in a scalable sense but it's
important to me because I want people to
know that I'm a real person and that
when they send me hey I'm wrestling with
this this or this that like there's a
person that's actually reading that and
trying to respond to them I mean I had I
literally had someone a few weeks ago
reply to me and say they were really
concerned about their physical health
and they were worried they weren't going
to be around for their kid you know 10
years from now if they didn't get their
weight in check and and they were having
trouble motivating and I said all right
well do 15 minutes walk just like walk
for 15 minutes tomorrow and email me
back and tell me that you did it and
they did that and I said all right do it
again tomorrow and then they did it
again tomorrow and it's just it's
interactions like that that I really
love like that's why I do this it's
because I feel like I can actually
create an impact and create value in
people's lives from my desk in New York
which is unbelievable to me it's a crazy
crazy thought relative to the path I was
on previously giving that up by not
being as human as I feel like I
naturally am feels like I'm giving in to
dark and negative forces that I don't
want to give into
hmm
yeah that that's that's a that's a nice
way of putting it I've kind of been
feeling the same thing where
you know in an Ideal World I would like
to share more because I think there's
value in sharing transparently about
things and kind of that human connection
but
there is that yeah I guess it's just
about weighing up the risk and the
benefits yeah um yeah I mean like look
uh
I have made plenty of money I'm doing
well I'm not the richest person in the
world like if you want to go rob someone
because they're super rich there's
plenty of people on the internet that
are richer than me that are like really
public about stuff they're doing with
money and I'm sure people can find them
um so I don't and I don't strive to I'm
not trying to be the richest person in
the world either that's just not like
what I really write about or what I talk
about it's just not part of my thing
um
I want to be extremely balanced and I
want to share ways that people can think
about their life so that they can build
that same comprehensively wealthy
existence that I feel like I've found
um and if that pisses people off along
the way I'd be surprised I don't I just
I really try to avoid things that I
think are going to piss people off
because I don't see a ton of value in it
I'm not one of the people that's gonna
like intentionally throw out rage bait
controversy just so that I can get a
bunch of views there's plenty of ways to
get views and that's not really one that
I find fun
what so you mentioned this idea I I
guess like comprehensively wealthy a
couple times what do you mean by that so
Wealth Beyond money changing the
scoreboard right like you know this is
what my book is about that I'm working
on now it's basically this whole idea
that we have been so narrowly focused on
money as the sole definition of wealth
throughout you know the last several
hundred years because it's so easily
measured you look up at the scoreboard
and your money scoreboard and you can
see it ticking up and down on a daily
basis right like I don't know if you've
ever used Mint or personal capital or
any one of these platforms people
refresh that thing daily just to see
like oh did my number go up I feel good
did it go down I feel bad that's how
they measure their whole life and that's
how they stack themselves up against
everyone else it's a it's a daily
scoreboard that you can look at and I
think we need a new scoreboard I think
that in order to live a truly happy and
fulfilled existence we need to expand
what is on our scoreboard and we need to
think about these other areas of life we
need to think about our physical health
and vitality we need to think about our
mental health mental Fitness mental
Vitality we need to think about our
social wealth cultural like environments
that we're in
um you know the people the depth of
relationships and we need to think about
our time most importantly you need to
think about being time wealthy and being
able to actually use our time while we
can use it there's this tendency of
humans of like deferred happiness
syndrome like oh I'm gonna do all those
things once I get to this point in my
life I'm gonna go on that vacation
travel the world once I can afford it or
once I've saved up this amount of money
or once I've reached this phase of my
career because I don't want to sacrifice
a year of my career you know trajectory
now and then have to start back there
next year and the reality is you're
never going to do those things and if
you do do them later down the line
you're just going to enjoy it less time
in the future is worth less than time
today it's just discounted what do you
mean
you know it's the same as money right
like a dollar in the future is worth
less than a dollar today it's the same
with time like you know a year a
year-long trip around the world at age
55 is less fun than a year-long trip at
age 35 because the things you can do as
a 35 year old single person traveling
the world are unbelievable like I had a
friend recently who I had this
discussion with
who is 27 years old he was on a path you
know Consulting getting promoted patted
on the back McKinsey like things are
great you're at you know you went you're
winning the game like you're going to be
a partner by 30 and that's like you're
calling card to life like Indian parents
man you're like really really nail and
winning the game
and he wanted to go travel for a year
rather than doing an MBA he wanted to go
travel and see different cultures he had
never traveled much and he said all of
the partners are telling me it's like
the worst decision because I'm going to
miss out on this ears this year of
growth and then I'm not going to make
partner by 30 it might take until I'm 32
and so I don't think I'm gonna do it and
I was like dude you're an idiot
I just was like that is the dumbest
reason to not do it because those years
you're never going to do this again this
is your one chance to do this you can
tell yourself oh I'm gonna do it you
know I'll do it you know once I've been
a partner for a while and I made a bunch
of money I'll do it when I'm 50. you
won't because you're going to have kids
that are in school you're going to have
kids that you're gonna have to pay to go
and do all sorts of different activities
you might have a wife you know you're
going to be all over the place and your
career is just going to have this
gravity it gets harder and harder to do
over the course of your life so if you
don't do it now you're not going to do
it so if you're comfortable with that
then that's fine you can make that
decision but don't convince yourself
that you're not doing it today because
you'll do it later hmm
I like to be I like to be aware whenever
I find myself in that in that model of
thinking I've been doing it a lot
recently because we're now in the sort
of final month of editing for the book
and so I keep on thinking in my mind
that like oh this is a thing for after
the book is done and the other day
um it felt a bit awkward to admit it um
it's but the other day actually like a
couple of days ago my mum me and my
grandma we were invited to drive to an
old friend's house to have a dinner
party
and I was thinking oh I really don't
want to go and it was like 4 P.M and I
was like oh you know we've got to be
there for seven I'm gonna have to drive
for two hours and then my mum and
grandma don't enjoy listening to music
in the car either so just like literally
driving in Silence with the occasional
bit of chatter and I have these book
deadlines coming up and this all these
things I need to do on the book
and I initially called my mum saying
that yeah how important is it that I go
to this dinner I don't really want to go
and she was like oh well you know think
about it it'll be nice if you come and
then I thought like
I I reflected on the thing that uh Tim
Urban has written about like the tail
end like the last number the last few
times you're going to spend with your
loved ones yeah and I was thinking in
the future will I will I ever think damn
I really regret not spending an extra
three hours on the book or am I more
likely to think damn I really wish I
could have one more road trip with my
mom and grandma and I was like obviously
the road trip yeah let's who cares if I
like it's gonna be a bit boring in the
car for some of the journey like yeah
I'm so glad I made that decision and it
was quite funny at the at the dinner as
well I met some new people
um but I I keep finding myself kind of
catching myself being like Oh if I'm
trying to defer something for one that
when the book is done because in my mind
when the book is done it's like it's
just around the corner and yeah you know
life will be easier then but then I
remind myself no hang on life's Never
Gonna feel easier there's always going
to be more stuff coming up and so if
it's important then it's going to be if
if it's important then it should be
important now rather than important in
the future
the yes damn effect have you heard of
this no what's up the yes damn effect is
this idea that uh we say yes to things
and then later say damn why did I say
yes to this and it's so true with most
people like you say yes to something
with the assumption that you're gonna
have more time a month from now so you
say like oh yeah I'll do that call next
month or yeah I'll do that speaking
engagement next month because I'm gonna
have much more time after the book I'm
gonna have much more time after X Y or Z
finishes I'm gonna have much more time
after the semester ends or whatever it
is and then you get there and you're
like damn why did I say yes to that so
the rule with the yes damn effect is
anytime you say yes to something under
the assumption that you're gonna have
more time for that thing in the future
you should just say no instead because
you're never going to have more time in
the future unless there's something
actually structurally changing in your
life where you're going to like make a
whole bunch more time or you're quitting
your job and you like there's something
massive structurally changing you're not
going to have more time in the future
especially not as an ambitious person
you're just going to take on some new
thing that is going to fill that time
yeah I found that while I was still
working full-time I kept on deferring a
lot of things I was like oh yeah once I
once I quit the job and I'll have all
the time in the world to be able to do
this and this and this and that and
ended up working more hours on like the
YouTube stuff and the business stuff
than I ever worked as a doctor and
suddenly all that free time disappeared
I was like whoa all that free time
go that I promised myself I would have
to be able to play more World of
Warcraft
I mean Tim Ferriss I think was one of
the first people to ever really talk
about this in four hour work week he
talked about how there's this massive
class of professional workers who you
know work in banking or consulting or
doctors or whatever it is where you ask
like hey why are you why are you working
so hard why are you doing this and their
answer is so that they can do X Y or Z
when they retire so that they have the
money to do X Y or Z so that I can
retire in Greece or so that I can like
buy a Vineyard and go retire on this
Vineyard you know in Napa or whatever it
is at the end of all that time and the
vast majority of them don't do it The
Wall Street Journal just released I
don't know if you saw this the Wall
Street Journal released a um a breakdown
of how people spend their time in
retirement and it was horrifying because
it was like four and a half hours a day
of watching TV was one of the things on
the list and it was basically a call to
action of if you think that you're you
know doing all of this work today so
that because you're going to have this
glamorous retirement living on the beach
and you know sipping pina coladas you're
kidding yourself what you're gonna end
up doing is sitting around and watching
television because you're going to be 70
and you're not going to have the energy
and the physical health to go do all
those things probably you're gonna have
to be stuck at home and for me what that
means is I really want to enjoy the
present like I want to be able to jump
on a plane on Monday morning fly to
London see you have a great dinner
together and then fly back and I have
the flexibility to do that in my life so
why not do it because I want to do that
now I don't want to wait until I finish
my book or until I hit some Financial
Milestone that's arbitrary that's just
going to change as soon as I get there
to whatever the next thing is I want to
really Embrace and really enjoy this
present moment
there's got to be a balance though right
so
um you might have come across the book
with the the defining decade no there oh
there are friends of mine that are
reading it recently I can't remember who
it's by but basically defining the the
defining decade argues that your 20s are
the or the defining decade and actually
your 20s are you know to quote garyvee
your 20s are for hustling well actually
I don't know if that's what garyvee says
these days um but your 20s are for
hustling and trying to get ahead in your
career so that you can actually set
yourself up financially to be more chill
and have more free time and stuff in
your 30s when you have a kid for the
first time and have the flexibility to
spend more time at home
and it feels to me like that's kind of
one side of the equation that kind of
actually it's worth working the extra
hours at McKinsey to get ahead to build
up that flexibility versus
hey I just want to travel the world for
five years and then what if you end up
in a place where actually financially
you're not able to hop on a plane on
Monday and chill in a restaurant yeah I
mean I'm 32. so I'm after my I did and I
did that I did the 80 to 100 hour weeks
from the time I was 22 until the time I
was 30 basically until I was 29. it
seems like now you're chilling yeah and
that built of financial Foundation that
mattered and it allowed me to actually
see where the gold was on my playing
field like you know if I had a map that
I was uncovering as like a video game
character around my map I spent those
years working so much that I found all
of the different areas of my map and
where I thought the gold was like where
my highest leverage opportunities were
to go deep and then I'm able to dig in
those areas which might not take more
than a couple hours a day and do much
better because I'm just digging up gold
I'm not digging up a bunch of crap
and so that matters like I really do
believe that the problem is the people
that say like I'm gonna hustle in my 20s
so that I can chill and spend time with
my kids in my 30s they're not gonna do
that they are not gonna chill and spend
time with their kids in their 30s
they're just gonna keep hustling because
you get to your 30s and you're on a
track like at a McKenzie or at an
investment bank or as a doctor or
whatever and then what you say is like
oh well you know now I'm now I'm doing
well I want to do even better like now I
made my first million I want to make
three million I want to make 5 million
because what it is is it's a mirage
you're like it's not just an age where
all of a sudden you wake up and you're
like now I'm gonna spend time with my
kids everything's great no you're like a
VP and you have tons of responsibilities
and the gravity of that career track has
only increased keeping you in it and the
golden handcuffs have only increased
because your lifestyle has crept up over
those years so now you know you might be
making a half a million dollars a year
feeling rich but your whole life is
crept up you're living in a nice
apartment you know you've got high tax
rate you like got the nice car that cost
you a a month and all of a sudden you're
like well crap I actually got to make a
million dollars for myself to feel rich
and then you make a million and you're
like damn I gotta make two million
dollars to actually feel rich and so
what happens is you don't get to 30 and
start chilling to hang out with your
kids you hustle through your 30s
thinking I'm gonna I'm gonna chill at
40. and then you get to 40 and maybe you
are ready to chill but your kids don't
want to hang out with you anymore
because they're 10 and they have friends
like the time from by the time they're
zero to ten I've seen someone call it
the magic years like that period from
zero to ten where they actually care
about you so much like you are their
favorite person in the entire world and
yet we work so hard during that period
of time we have no time we're traveling
we're doing whatever it is and that's a
real travesty in my opinion and so if
you could actually do that if you could
hustle in your 20s to build the
foundation to figure out your highest
leverage opportunities and then dive in
to where those High leverage
opportunities are that's what I'm doing
and I think it's amazing if you can make
it work but most people won't do that
most people will just continue to work
harder and harder because they see
whatever the next version of more is
whatever the next Mirage is on the
horizon and they just keep blindly
walking towards it hmm
have you seen the um or have you read
um that this is water speech David
Foster Wallace yeah I've come across it
from a few different sources okay so you
know it's like um he starts it with this
Parable that these two fish are swimming
along in the water and an older fish
swims on up to them and is like hey boys
how's the water and the two other fish
kind of continue swimming along and then
one of them looks at the other one and
says what the hell is water and it's
this whole idea like you know
tongue-in-cheek cheeky comment of we're
very much blind to our most obvious
realities and when you are on that
hustle phase and when you're continuing
to progress and doing all those those
things you are blind to these obvious
realities of the things that you're
missing you're just you you've grown
accustomed to what that track is and you
need to continue feeding that track
because our culture just tells us that
success means getting promoted every two
years that success means getting a pay
raise of 10 every year that getting the
big bonus that's what success looks like
and so that's what you have to actually
go and do in order to continue to feed
that beast in your life
[Music]
um
yeah
I'm just thinking like is there a
is there an easy mental model for this
to kind of
balance out on the one hand the idea
that you you gotta hashtag hustle in
your 20s to build a foundation versus
you actually do want to chill yeah I
mean I think it's
um the way I've always thought about it
the like simple heuristic for it is
you work hard first so that you can work
smart later okay those two were always
played off of each other in tension it
was like you're either working hard or
you're working smart
and I just don't I don't think their
intention I think they're sequential I
think that it's really important to work
hard early in your career I will never
tell anyone like oh don't you know just
work smarter in your career bugged me to
no end when people would join you know
our firm as 22 year olds and want all
this balance and want to be able to like
spend time with all their friends and
you know have the high paying job and
it's like I just think you have to pick
one you can spend time with tons of your
friends and like go work at the cushy
you know Google gig or whatever but that
wasn't the career track where you're in
you need to work hard if you want to
accelerate and build great things
um
and then you can work smart once you've
done that once you've built that base
once you've built that Foundation the
hard work is important because what I
said earlier you need to uncover the map
you need to uncover what the high
leverage opportunities are for you
because you don't know when you're
starting at age 22 you have no idea
what's out there you don't know what
you're good at you don't know what
you're bad at you don't know where the
gold is on the map you don't know where
the gold is going to be on the map in
the future because you have no
heuristics you have no tools at your
disposal you're just starting to learn
and the hard work the saying yes to tons
of opportunities that come your way the
hours that come with that that's what
allows you to see the map I mean the
same goes for Content creators it's like
I don't know a single content creator
that has become big that didn't grind in
the early days of getting things going
there's no easy way to do it there's no
like hack to building one of these
things you spend hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of hours creating and
banging your head into a wall and
frustrated because something didn't take
off the way you thought it should but
all of those little things contribute to
where you are in the end it's like the
stone cutter analogy of you know the
stone color cutter is chipping away at
the stone over and over again you don't
see a single you know in the stone
and then suddenly the whole thing breaks
and you would never say that those
hundred cracks at it had no impact they
clearly were just doing a little bit of
damage a little bit of damage a little
bit of damage that you just couldn't see
but they were an integral part of
actually splitting the thing open at the
end and so I think that exact same thing
applies to the way that we work in our
lives you have to do all of that hard
work up front because that's what allows
you to effectively work smart once you
get to that point
hmm nice
there's a there's another way I've been
sort of slowly thinking about it I think
prompted by something that Naval once
tweeted
um along with my own my own kind of
thoughts on what is like what does
retirement mean and
I think I kind of sort of synthesized
this into like three things retirement
is either where
you have so much money that your your
expenses are taken care of and therefore
you don't need to work
or where
your expenses are so low that the money
you do have coming in is like you know
the lean fire and all that kind of stuff
it's so low that actually you're a
functionally retired and you don't need
to work or where the stuff that you're
doing for work is the stuff you would be
doing anyway and therefore you feel like
you don't need to work yeah and I feel
like for me I've been like I've spent my
20s trying to kind of tick all three
boxes
um doing a bit less well on the sort of
Lifestyle inflation front but that's
kind of it was a little bit in the back
of my mind let's try and let's try and
make money preferably through hashtag
passive income so that it's not directly
tied to my time but at the same time let
me try and move to a place where the
work I'm doing is the work that I
actually would choose to be doing even
if I wasn't being paid for it yep and so
these days I feel so grateful because
like it's a Tuesday morning today I got
up I had a shower and I was so excited
to do a one-on-one with Angus my general
manager and then I was so excited
because we had some team meetings we
were planning out content and then I was
super excited for this that we're gonna
hang out afterwards for dinner as well
I'm just like dab I can't believe that
this is what I get to do for work it's a
cool feeling isn't it yeah it's mental
and people looking in my life would say
oh you work too hard
um but I'd be like it really doesn't
feel like it and I played loads of
Hogwarts Legacy for the like you know
over the last couple of weeks it's
really good um and
that's kind of been the future that I've
been trying to trying to work towards
ever since the age of 18 when I read the
four I work week for the first time yeah
yeah I mean I think the um
the points you made are really good ones
right like my my whole setup and what
I've been trying to build is very
similar it's like I have all this Media
stuff that I do the writing the creating
um you know the brand building that is
part of what I do and a challenging part
in terms of the time and the energy that
I put into it but I'm untethered from
having to do that because I have this
holding company that owns you know today
six businesses under it that are cash
flowing a whole lot and that are
continuing to grow and that I don't have
to operate every single day because
there are competent people running all
of them and so there's this amazing cash
flow engine that I don't touch and that
I actually shouldn't touch because I'll
probably go screw something up with it
if I do that unlocks me to go and focus
on the things that I really enjoy on a
daily basis so that I can fly to London
for a day to go see some people and do
things like this and not have to worry
that I'm not like replying to emails or
you know getting something done or
posting on the Cadence that I
necessarily need to post on because it
has no impact on my overall financial
status
um and that's an amazing feeling
I am delighted to say that this podcast
is very kindly sponsored by 80 000 hours
and 80 000 hours is one of my favorite
organizations in the world they are a
non-profit that helps people have a more
positive impact with their career and
the reason they're called 80 000 hours
is because a career is on average 80 000
hours long it's around 40 hours a week
for 50 weeks a year for around 40 years
which adds up to 80 000 hours that's a
very very long time until the objective
of 80 000 hours is to help you find a
fulfilling career that also has a
positive impact in the world and the
best part is there are complete
non-profit they are not trying to make
any money from this at all and so the
organization is sick I've interviewed a
bunch of their members here on this
podcast and they've literally spent the
last decade conducting a bunch of
research around what makes a career
fulfilling and also what makes a career
positively impactful in the world
they've been doing this research
alongside academics at places like
Oxford University and actually for me
personally when I was struggling to
figure out what to do with my career I
basically binged every single post on 80
000 hours.org which is the website and I
also had a careers counseling session
with one of their careers counselors and
those two things just like reading all
this stuff understanding what are the
factors that actually lead to an
impactful career and how can I combine
those with my own personal passions and
skills really helped me to formulate
that actually this career as being a
quote thought leader YouTuber podcaster
whatever I'm doing now I actually felt
more meaningful and impactful for me
than continuing to be a doctor so yeah
everything they provide is completely
free they're a non-profit and their only
aim is to help you find a fulfilling and
impactful career and if you want to get
a completely free copy of their in-depth
career guide then head over to 80 000
hours.org forward slash Deep dive and if
you enter your email over there again
completely for free they're not trying
to make any money from this if you enter
your email they will send you the career
guide which is basically the crash
course in the main ideas that make for a
fulfilling and high impact career so
head to 80 000 hours.org that's eight
zero zero zero zero hours hawors.org
forward slash deep dive and that will
give you so much more information on how
to start planning or changing your
career to something that's fulfilling
and meaningful and has a positive impact
on the world so thank you so much 80 000
hours for very kindly sponsoring this
episode the other way that I kind of
think about this is in the context of
tabletop board games
um there's you know games like uh Katan
and these other more more kind of
fancier ones there's always some kind of
you some kind of production engine or
some kind of economic engine whether
it's you know in Agricola you have your
little workers in the farm and you're
generating units of food or you've got
your little sheep and you're generating
units of sheep or in Catan like wood and
hay and so and all that crap
and whenever you're playing one of these
board games
you have to have an economic engine of
some sort yeah you you can't just play
the game and just be like I'm just gonna
build an army yeah with with what's like
yeah you've got to have some kind of
production machine
and so in my in the back of my mind
there's this analogy of everyone
everyone needs an economic engine of
some sort either that's the trust fund
from your parents or from your
grandparents or whatever that might be
in which case great or rather not not so
great
um but you've got to figure out what's
what's going to drive that engine and
preferably and I guess this is the place
where you've gone to with your holding
company the more you can untether that
from your physical hours invested the
more you're able to unlock Freedom yeah
and optionality for yourself and that
means you can choose to you know move
across the country to hang out with your
parents or come to London or you just
unlocks freedom in your life yeah and
that's the freedom to choose to invest
in the things you actually want to
invest your time in because the
objective isn't to sit in the beach
sipping pina coladas the objective is to
you know at least for me to you know
have freedom away from the things I
don't want to do and freedom to do the
things that I actually do want to do
without feeling like I'm chuckled to a
job that is forcing me to yeah do a
certain thing do you ever feel that way
with creating videos do you ever have to
like feel like oh man I have to create a
video this week and I'm not excited
about what I have to create yes and that
whenever I feel that like that's always
a little bit of like a hmm
I was feeling that a lot for our
part-time YouTuber Academy which is the
live course that I've been running for
the last two and a half years which is
why this is like we're in the middle of
the very last one because I realized
that yes it's making a couple million a
year but like it's it's not worth it
because when it comes around to it
I do feel like I'm having to do it this
time around it's different because I'm
like I'm doing it for the last time so
now I'm really bringing all the energy
and it's like so good sure
um I'll go back to the um you mentioned
Naval earlier there's a naval quote that
has been that is like always really
resonated with me and it kind of defined
what I'm actually going after in life
and it was a Fit Body a calm mind and a
house full of love these are things that
cannot be bought they must be earned
a Fit Body a calm mind and a house full
of love
and that to me is like my Guiding Light
when I think about things like what do I
want I want to achieve things that have
to be earned that cannot be bought
that and that's what I want in life I
want to go after the things that I have
to earn I just think there's this
massive importance of actually going out
and earning things rather than being
given to you or rather than just being
able to you know buy them and you know
manifest them and do money
um it's like uh
if you were to be placed at the top of a
mountain today like we picked you up out
of here out of this chair and dropped
you off at the top of a mountain you
would pass out because you wouldn't be
acclimatized to the altitude you would
literally pass out and the same goes for
anything in life if you haven't earned
it through actually going through the
climb you're going to get there and
you're gonna get knocked out cold
because you haven't grown acclimated to
the to the altitude over time it's the
reason in my opinion people that win the
lottery often go bankrupt or people that
come into a ton of money like athletes
often you know make a ton of money at a
very young age and end up going bankrupt
because if you feel like you haven't
earned it you haven't had those
incremental steps along the way to
actually like build up that
understanding of what it is and what you
need and what you know you're kind of
acclimatizing to it over time it's
really challenging when it's all of a
sudden dropped into your lap and so I'm
really focused on those things that I
have to earn and really going after
those
um and pursuing those in a deep way
my way of thinking is similar it's less
about things I have to earn and more
about well I guess uh somewhat similar
because it's more about
will I personally learn something from
doing this and so
for example in this recent cohort of a
course like I read a lot about sales and
marketing and now I feel I have leveled
up my own personal
stock price or personal like money
making power because I Now understand at
least something about sales and
marketing and I've applied it in this
context
and now I you know danco and Dicky Bush
were talking about it in a podcast the
other day that I really vibed with the
idea of
rather than Financial Security Financial
confidence
so Financial Security I think is the
thing that I've been chasing for feeling
like a four percent withdrawal rate and
let's have a couple million in the S P
500 and all that kind of stuff but it's
I've never felt financially secure
because it always feels like I need more
and more money to build up more and more
of a safety net but since I started
thinking in more in terms of financial
confidence it's more about regardless of
what happens I have the skills needed to
make money if need be because I know how
to build a business
for example and that has given me more
confidence to be able to adapt to
other kind of environments and I found
that Since switching my thinking there
I've gone away from the scarcity
thinking of
ah but I really should I I really should
film this YouTube video because we have
we've got a sponsor deadline and like I
kind of feel like I have to do it and
more towards
because like you know right now things
are going well if things ever end up not
going well I've got the skills to be
able to
build something up from scratch
completely from scratch if I wanted to
and the more I feel like I can embody
that Financial confidence the more it
frees me up because I do sometimes feel
like I'm on a bit of a hamster wheel
with content creation and all that kind
of stuff I think that's natural yeah
something that I see in a lot of content
creators I mean I asked like
every content creator that I spend time
with do you ever feel though I I felt
that way from time to time although I
don't make a whole lot of money off my
content you know my newsletter I
sometimes feel that way but I only you
know I send it twice a week the Friday
one is more of like a kind of curation
so that never feels like a ton of work
because I'm it's just things I'm
consuming during the course of the week
it's relatively easy the Wednesday one
now and then I have so many things I
think about on a daily basis it never
feels like I'm stretching to write
something
um and I so I don't I never feel like
it's the core of my economic engine
which prevents me from feeling like
there's a there's a hamster wheel
sometimes I feel it in the context of
growth because I'm so growth oriented
that I just want to be growing on all
the platforms which means you have to
create on all the platforms you need to
be putting out a tweet a YouTube you
know or a Instagram video a LinkedIn
post like every single day and if you
don't have anything to say well it's
like well okay what am I going to
post what do I have to think I got to
think about it and that sometimes can
feel that way but again I come back to
like okay so what like I'm just not
gonna post anything it's okay it doesn't
matter
um what motivates you like why like when
you talk about
um
when you talk about uh wanting to you
know level up your skills and you know
you say like because then I can you know
earn money no matter what and if things
go bad I can make money like what are
you are you trying to make a certain
amount of money like what is the what is
the goal like what are you really trying
to do underlying all of this it's a good
question I think I am trying to do
essentially I'm trying to play I'm I'm
trying to keep on playing my infinite
game in the sense that right now
I feel like if I won the lottery
there is very little that would change
about my schedule
I wouldn't other than the fact I
wouldn't run courses anymore and I would
not take on any sponsorships those are
like the two areas where the reason I'm
doing the thing is for the money
but I would still make YouTube videos I
was still a podcast I will still hang
out with people like you and I would
still want to have a team that helped me
create content and share it with the
world because that's the thing that
brings me in intrinsic joy in some
capacity like teaching and sharing and
stuff
and so given that that's the infinite
game What I'm trying to optimize for is
just being able to continue living that
kind of life where
I can wake up every morning and think
that yeah I don't I don't need I don't
have to do something and I think the
reason I feel so I'm so like tied to
that idea is because
throughout my time in medical school and
throughout my time working
I saw so many examples of doctors who
hated their lives
and the reason they hated their lives
was because basically because they
didn't have enough money they would
choose to go part-time if they could but
they couldn't go part-time because they
needed they had a certain lifestyle
mortgages etc etc
um a lot of them would would have wanted
to quit the job completely and like take
a break from medicine to travel the
world or to do something else or to
build a business or whatever the thing
might be or even spend more time with
their kids but they couldn't because
they didn't have enough money and so
I've seen firsthand that that future
where being a doctor is supposed to be a
fulfilling and job where you help people
and all that kind of stuff yeah actually
I'd say at least half the doctors I've
ever met were just like so chronically
dissatisfied with their life that it
made me feel like damn I never want to
be in that position where I feel like
I'm Shackled to a job for the sake of
the money and so right now I feel great
because it's like the thing that I'm
doing for fun is also the thing that
makes money but the thing that keeps me
up at night is what if this all crumbles
down what if the YouTube channel starts
to decline because every YouTuber has a
growth phase and then a plateau and then
a slow decline over time you become a
has been no one cares about your content
anymore AI is taking over like why does
that happen I've always wondered that
like
from the very early days of doing my
Creator stuff I started building these
like businesses that are underneath the
holding company because
I had had that realization that like no
one really wants to create for longer
than some period of time and it's
probably not how long I'm going to be
wanting to do things for earning money
for and so I need to be building things
that have either Enterprise Value or
they have you know that I can sell or
they have cash flow that I can be
converting into other things that are
going to generate income in the future
um and I need that because I know I'm
not going to be wanting to do the things
that make money from a media standpoint
forever there's going to be some point
where either I'm burned out or you know
whatever it is so what what do you think
contributes to that you know that
natural curve that people have like the
growth phase the plateaus yeah
I've I feel like
okay so I haven't haven't really thought
of that too hard but but let's think out
loud so I think the people in
entertainment like the lifestyle type
vloggers and things have a way steeper
rise and steeper decline because it's so
based on like
people following their personality or
their Vibe at a certain stage of life
like for example the people that most
people watched when they were teenagers
the vloggers and stuff that were doing
pranks are probably not the same people
as the ones are watching when they're 25
years old and so the in some cases the
audience literally outgrows the Creator
I think in other cases and I see this
often in education
if for example you are a
garyvee and people are consuming your
stuff at some point they get the message
and they do their own thing and they
stop consuming ROV stuff because it's no
longer relevant for them and so there's
natural churn in the garyvee audience
where you no longer need to consume
personal development
like I would say Tim Ferriss is the one
person outside of my family who's most
changed my life but these days I consume
0.1 of this content but if I ever met
Tim Ferris and Tim Ferriss in real life
I'd be like oh my God mate you've
changed my life so much like I've
listened I listened to every episode of
the podcast from like zero to 150 and
then I stopped because then I built my
own thing based on the inspiration I
took away from that
so there's natural tone in the audience
in that sense I think Tech YouTubers
have done a good job of staying relevant
for a long time like Marquez and Linus
and stuff have been around 15 years and
still and show no signs of declining
because I think then the focus is on the
tech and every year a new tech comes out
and therefore there's new stuff to cover
and so their expertise on this new thing
of tech becomes more valuable over time
rather than less valuable but I think
there's a yeah I feel like there's just
a
I think there has to be a just like
natural
burnout not necessarily burnout in the
sense of like oh my God I'm burnt out
yeah but it's just a lot of work to
continue to create videos over a long
period of time to continue to feel like
you need to be on to be like in a sense
performative like it is you're
performing you're like acting in a
certain way and we all play a character
in in our lives right like at some point
during your day
when you turn on the cameras for us to
come in here like we perk up a little
bit Yeah and we're smiling and we're
talking and not that we weren't doing
this before we turned on the cameras and
like all of a sudden it's this big
acting show but you turn on and that's
tiring when you do that day in and day
out for 10 years it's still it's just a
lot and so not only is there like
potentially a demand side thing of you
know people not necessarily wanting your
content after a certain period of time
but there's also the supply like you the
supplier of it might be tired at some
point of doing you know the same type of
thing or feeling like you're creating
the same video like personal finance or
Finance people it's like how many
dividend videos can I possibly make
before I've like talked about dividend
stocks and like I know what I'm creating
and for me
you know I I would say that like at the
very early days of creating my content
online and when I was writing on Twitter
it was like it was very much about Niche
Finance stuff and I was writing about
that and I just realized very quickly
like man I don't like writing about this
stuff I am bored and I because I didn't
care about it it didn't matter to me it
wasn't a big part of my life it was what
I was doing for a job my day job and so
it felt natural that I had credibility
to write about it but I realized like if
I'm going to have longevity in this I
need to expand my circle of things I can
talk about and you know you get yelled
at every single time you expand your
circle like someone will say like stay
in your lane bro whatever like you know
when I wrote about mental models people
were like oh you know stay in your lane
why are you writing about mental models
or you know when I started writing about
philosophy stuff people were like whoa
like you can't write about that you're a
finance guy whatever it is yeah and
I've been pretty intentional about
trying to just write about my own life
struggles now you know like I'm kind of
on a journey now where like I went from
writing about like the hustle bro type
stuff of the early days to
you know relationship things and my wife
and I going through having a kid and now
like being a dad and contending with
like what that looks like and balancing
that across wanting to perform well as a
professional person but also being an
amazing dad and there's a lot of people
on that Journey as it turns out like
there's a lot of people who are trying
to wrestle with that and are going on
that same life journey and so my bet is
that I actually don't have to ever give
anyone answers like everyone is always
saying
oh you know like T you know that you're
teaching things like for you for your
YouTube like you're teaching things
right like people say like oh you're a
great teacher you're doing all this
stuff I actually don't feel like either
of us and I certainly don't feel it for
myself that that I'm a teacher I feel
like I'm learning things and I'm sharing
what I learn along the way and I say
that on my profile but I it really means
something to me because no one has the
answers to offer you for your life
there's no one in the world who can say
hey here here are the answers that I can
give you and if you do this this this
this and this you're going to be on the
path to a successful life and you know
there go off and you're going to be
successful what I can do is help you ask
the right questions and give you tools
give you Frameworks give you systems for
asking those questions so that you can
wrestle with them and figure out what
your answers are because your answers
are going to be different than mine and
what you want and what your definition
of success looks like and what motivates
you your idol of you know what you're
being motivated by on a daily basis it's
just going to be different than mine and
that's great that's the beauty of it
actually is that we're all on our own
journey and so I'm just so much more
focused now and it's what's allowing me
I think to be excited after these couple
of years and to have longevity around it
hopefully is
thinking more about questions and
struggle than about answers and like
I've accomplished anything yeah yeah I
think that's pretty pretty similar to
how I think about it
um I you know came across an interesting
way of thinking about this through my
writing coach a couple years ago which
was
you don't need to be a guru you can be a
guide instead like God versus Guru
um and you sometimes don't even need to
be a guide you can be a fellow traveler
along the same path yeah stumbling
traveler
and I I think about that a lot um this
is why still to this day
um a lot of our videos are titled like
how I do X like I was working on right
now about how I manage my time where I
was thinking yeah in this video I'm just
going to share three strategies plus
like a Google Sheets template that I've
been getting a lot of value out in the
last six months to help me take better
care of my time and maybe the more
better things like you know 10 tips to
manage your time or 10 tips to level up
your life life-changing tips for
managing your time that kind of stuff
but you won't believe number seven
there's just part of me that feels that
that kind of stuff it doesn't feel
authentic because I don't like just like
you I don't feel like I figured anything
out yeah I just have a few things that
work for me yeah having tried lots of
things share them online why not the one
thing that we take for granted for sure
is
we might feel like we're just a traveler
alongside on the path but
from someone else's perspective we might
look like the expert alpinist that's on
the path next to them yeah and we might
be next to them and travel in the past
we might not be the guide or the guru or
whatever it is
but we look different than them in terms
of how we're pursuing it and that's
inspiring and so if you can share like
you know you have the good equipment and
the polls and the you know the good
technique of how you're climbing or how
you're hiking that's really valuable to
other people if you can just share that
while you're walking alongside them
that's an amazing thing yeah and we live
in this world where there's effectively
zero bounds to doing that it's just our
energy you know I like I joke about this
a lot that
when you're young
you have Infinite Energy like when
you're 25 think about when you're 25
like when I was 25 I had infinite energy
and I assumed that I was always going to
have infinite energy that my whole life
I was just gonna be like this fired up
about everything and I could work for so
many hours and do all this stuff the
reality is that as you get older your
energy becomes more and more finite and
the whole game becomes figuring out how
to deploy that finite energy and create
the greatest output create those
non-linear outcomes that exist and
getting better and better at that over
time is what the real focus should be it
should be figuring out how to deploy
that finite energy into the 10x things
into the areas that create the most
leverage that you can achieve those
non-linear outcomes we were talking
about the idea of
um kind of comprehensive wealth flag
wealth in Old areas of life and kind of
we talked a bit about wealth in terms of
time uh We've we've talked a little bit
a bit about like physical wealth I guess
um what sort of stuff do you think about
when it comes to mental mental clarity
guess mental health and well-being and
that kind of stuff yeah I sort of bucket
this into I suppose three areas I mean
one is on the mental side
feeling like you are working on things
that light you up that like you know
people say light your soul on fire I
think that is one of the highest mental
callings that any of us can have you
know like the whole fire movement of you
know financially independent retire
early the retire early part sounds
shitty to me I don't want to retire like
I don't want to be 40 and not working on
anything meaningful again I've had
friends who have done that I got a
friend this guy Val katiev who you might
have seen on Twitter who probably made a
hundred million dollars by the time he
was 30 and he tried to retire and he
started gardening because he was so
bored he started gardening and he said
he drove himself nuts like he didn't
know what to do with himself he had
retired but he was a driven entrepreneur
like he was really thoughtful he wanted
to be working on something and so now
he's like doing you know 100 things
again he has no Financial reason to but
he's doing all these different things
um and so that's one for me on the
mental well side is like just working on
things that you find meaningful and that
you find exciting that really light you
up on a daily basis the second one is
like what I call mental Fitness which is
decision making you know learning and
growth you know the ability to kind of
like cut through the noise and really
make sound decisions non-emotional
decisions
um and accumulate knowledge over time so
that you can make better and better
decisions I think like Shane parish's
work Farnam Street is like the master of
this like where I learned mental Fitness
from was like reading all of his
writings and his his different work over
time and absorbing the best lessons from
the smartest people in the world like
you talk about Tim Ferriss and all you
learned from him there's probably 20
people on my list that I feel like I've
learned so much from and that I'm now
excitingly getting to kind of meet and
tell them and thank them for that but
building up that base where you feel
like you're learning and growing and
developing your mental acuity and mental
Fitness and then the third piece is
mental health
and you know for me I bucket mental
health with like mindfulness
spirituality like an ability to you know
to both look within and to think about
my own position you know within I don't
know the broader world and like contend
with the bigger questions of meaning and
and and life and purpose
um but that's the third area that I
really think is important to to get
around and and frankly one that like men
traditionally have not
thought about and have neglected and me
you know coming from an athletic
background I never would have talked
about mental health 10 years ago like in
a locker room you're talking about
mental health and now in hindsight many
of my teammates and myself like we were
struggling with things mentally and we
didn't feel like we had people we could
open up to I saw this stat recently that
50 of men don't feel like they have a
single friend that they can open up to
about
vulnerable things
and that is a massive travesty I mean
really it's a loneliness epidemic we
feel alone whether or not we can be
surrounded by people in a pub and you
can feel totally alone
and that's really really sad that we
don't have people that we can open up to
in that way and it's damning and
impactful negatively on our lives
what are your practices on the mental
health front mindfulness meditation do
you do any of that kind of stuff I've
never been able to get myself to
meditate
on a daily basis I have I would say two
one has been the cold plunge
um you know I go and get into freezing
cold water at about 4 30 in the morning
every single morning how how and why
does that work what's what's going on
there so I mean the cold plunge has now
become this like very trendy thing
because Andrew huberman you know has
made it really popular and it's become
this very polarizing thing on Twitter
and on all the you know different
platforms of like doing the cold plunge
part of the reason it's been polarizing
by the way is because there was a period
of time where if you just posted a video
of yourself doing a cold plunge like
every day on Instagram you could like
pretty reliably build like 50 000
follower audience just because they were
like popping off like every single video
would just take off
um the cold punch for me there are all
sorts of physical health benefits that
are purported you know that like
different Studies have found that to me
like if any of that is true that's all
upside and bonus
I view it as a purely mental activity
where I wake up first thing in the
morning and I have to exert a degree of
Mind Control in order to get myself to
do this because I don't want to do it
it's miserable if you go and you're
getting into freezing cold water out on
my deck which is outside in the cold I
got out of my warm bed 4 30 in the
morning is Pitch Black and I have to go
outside on my deck and go get into this
water
and for me every single morning I you
know the mental gymnastics starts I'm
like I don't need to do this I could do
it later it actually be better for me if
I do it later because then I'll like
really stay in there longer whatever you
start convincing yourself and I have to
exert that control over myself to say
like nope I said I'm gonna do this I'm
going to go outside and I'm gonna do it
and when you do that
it's like a little bit of confirmation
bias in your life where your beliefs
start creating your reality your beliefs
about yourself as a disciplined person
that does the things that you say you're
going to do start getting confirmed by
evidence that you're accruing you create
like a little positive momentum of this
piece of evidence that you just put on
the board that you are doing the things
that you say you're going to do and that
momentum starts bleeding out into
everywhere else in your life and so I do
that every single morning as a way to
just like get uncomfortable and take on
some level of voluntary struggle
so that whenever the involuntary
struggles of Life happen I'm more well
prepared for them
I also find it to be the most peaceful
gratitude practice that I can have I Let
Go and I sit in the water and you're
like feeling this crazy experience of
like the sensations of like your body's
kind of screaming stressful situation
and you need to force yourself to just
slow down and every morning when I do
that I just list off things that I'm
feeling particularly grateful for you
know my son my wife family you know a
bird that's flying overhead whatever it
is like things that I'm just observing
or noticing in the moment and it just
forces you to like really slow down your
world and stop for one moment every
single morning prior to the whole day
going into chaos so that is one thing
and the second big mindfulness practice
I've found is just going for walks every
single day I probably walk for about
three hours every single day oh wow
um partially because I have a son who
refuses to sleep other than on walks
during the course of the day and so I
will take him on to you know hour and a
half long walks all around our
neighborhood and that time you know
while also being with him because we're
like connected in some way is just like
the time when I kind of slow down and I
can just think and I don't I'm not
listening to podcasts I'm not listening
to audiobooks I know you're probably
like cringing what do you mean you're
not listening yeah my goodness that's
like two audio books a day yeah so you
know and I could I could read 20 you
know I could read 20 books a year I'm
sure about doing that but for me that
time
is for thinking like that's when all the
ideas are sort of like mingling in my
mind when I'm able to actually
um you know just like let my mind run
free and that has been a massive massive
positive for my mental health finding
that time
nice
uh a couple of weeks ago I started
turning the shower to cold after a warm
shower and now I feel like that's kind
of become too easy and I don't I don't
fear it anymore have you ever tried
getting into a cold shower I've not
tried getting into it yeah
that's the next level of yours by the
way are actually harder than getting
into a cold plunge I mean cold plunge is
full of emerging something about the
shower for me is really hard with like
the beads of water hitting you it's
almost like sometimes sometimes the cold
plunge you know it's on my deck and so
there were times when it would like be
freezing rain or snow and it's actually
worse sitting there when you have like
rain hitting you in the face than if you
were just underwater so like sometimes I
would be sitting there in the cold rain
would be hitting me in the face while my
whole body was submerged in water and
the rain hitting me in the face was more
unnerving than the actual cold on my
body so I would just like take a breath
and go underneath in the freezing water
um so I actually think cold plunges are
a little bit easier than the cold shower
also just the ability to just turn the
knob like you know it's there you can
stop it at any point is mentally quite
jarring
yeah as you were describing that that
mental challenge of like putting in the
discipline and doing the thing even
though you don't want to do the thing
I was thinking I sometimes feel that
about YouTube videos and that's kind of
what I was thinking when when you when
you asked me if it feels like like a
grind sometimes or or however we were
talking about it
because there is that inertia to getting
started but usually once I've gotten
started then I enjoy the process and
then I film the video and afterwards I'm
always so glad like oh
damn it's almost like an hour filming I
feel like I shared something valuable
which at least one person is going to
find helpful I get to just give the SD
card to our editor who's amazing and
then just deals with it and then a
couple of weeks later a video will come
out on the channel and there'll be
comments from people being like wow this
was super helpful
but it does feel like yeah I have to do
a lot of procrastination beforehand I'll
make like multiple cups of coffee and
I'll be like anyone in the team need me
for anything while we're here it's like
all right let's maybe go for a walk
because people say going for a walk is
good eventually I'll come down to sit
down to doing the video and then I'll be
reading glad I did the video and there's
part of me that's like
I I sometimes wonder if I'm bullshitting
myself in that I tell myself that
the life I'm living now is the life I
would choose to live if I if I wasn't
concerned about money
but yeah I still make kind of three
videos a week and I don't always enjoy
the opening process of making those
videos I'm always glad I did I did it at
the end
and I kind of think that like
I I don't know the answer here but I
sometimes wonder
should I just make fewer videos so that
I only film videos when I feel like it
or is it actually a good thing for me
that I am pushing myself to do this
thing that feels uncomfortable initially
but I'm always glad for it in the long
run
I think doing hard things is important I
mean you're doing something hard like
you're doing something challenging and
you're pushing yourself through it I
don't think it's I don't think you would
find
incredible meaning in a life where you
only did things that you were like super
excited to do that's just not that lacks
texture right like that lacks those
feelings the tension the like
um the struggle on a daily basis that
actually creates some level of meaning
in our lives like when we don't Embrace
friction we've lived in this world where
friction has been consistently reduced
over our entire lifetime technology has
just reduced the amount of friction in
everything you no longer have to go to
the store if you don't want to you no
longer have to talk to people if you
don't want to if you want to go out and
date you don't have to actually take on
the fear of approaching someone at the
bar you can just do it through an app
and decide if you like each other before
actually having to meet in person
friction has just gone like this over
time and at some point
friction actually was what created
meaning in our lives like it was what
led to the funny stories of like oh I
walked up to that girl and she rejected
me and then I slipped and fell and it's
really fun you like later get to talk
about that and I often wonder
are our lives going to be significantly
less interesting than our parents and
grandparents like when I hear my mom who
grew up in India tell stories about her
childhood or my grandmother you know in
India tell stories about her childhood
they are so interesting their day-to-day
lives because they didn't have phones
they didn't have anything they were out
they had to do things they had to like
go roam through the streets and meet up
with friends and get into all sorts of
high drinks and I kind of got to do that
when I was a kid we're the last
generation that got to do that when we
were kids now everyone is kids are
sitting on their phones all day they're
like playing video games all day they're
on their computers all day they're not
allowed to go anywhere without tons of
supervision and I really wonder like
with my own son what is he gonna do like
what is he gonna tell people at a
cocktail party like what stories what
funny moments is he gonna have from his
childhood because
I think we're just steadily reducing the
friction that exists and as a result
steadily reducing the interesting things
and the interesting moments that are
happening on a daily basis
that's probably the one thing I miss
most about medicine
where
they just like the stories and the
interesting moments like
when I hang when I hang out with my
medic friends
I don't I don't miss anything about the
lifestyle other than the fact when
they're like oh you know the other night
like it was it was a nightmare we had
three patients that were bleeding out in
front of me and we were understaffed and
like people were on strike and so you
know blah blah blah blah happened and
then like yeah one of the patients ended
up dying and that wouldn't have happened
if we'd had enough staff and it's like
bloody hell real stuff like things like
that where I'm like like that was
my life yeah and now my life is this
very chill
I get to rock up in a cushy house with a
camera's pre-set up for me and yeah and
do podcasts with people who I enjoy
enjoy chatting to that there's no
there's no real sense of challenge do
you stress about views
do you stress about engagement and Views
and like are you do you kind of feel
this is the one thing I hate the reason
I ask is because this is the one thing I
hate about social media and about the
Platforms in general is I have at times
and I'm getting better about it now I'm
quite good about it I'm in the stretch
where I'm quite good about it I've at
times like allowed it to truly impact my
day and my mood of like something that I
did or spent a bunch of time on it's not
going the way I wanted it to or it
hasn't taken off and I thought it should
and I'm in a bad mood and I'm not
present with my wife or with my son and
then something does really well and I'm
all of a sudden like you know chipper
chipper sahil over here like talking
everything's great whatever and I
realized that and I had to have like
like come to Jesus talk with myself oh
well you can't let that kind of
thing impact you
um do you find that like are you when a
video doesn't take off the way you think
it should do you feel
drained bummed how does it impact you
um I've definitely gotten better at it
over time and it does sort of sine wave
a little bit these days I'm at a phase
where I almost never even look at the
numbers like videos will come out on the
channel I wouldn't even realize it I'll
just go on YouTube on my phone because
I'm browsing something I see oh there's
some notifications oh people are coming
oh the video's out oh that's cool let me
get off the toilet so I can actually
watch the video well well I've got a
loom recording so I can give artists
feedback and just be like yup sick oh
nice that was sick that was cool yeah
well played that was really good poker
music here could be a little bit
different yeah and I broadly don't look
at the numbers I I will occasionally
look at them um but right now we're in a
period where the channel is growing
faster than it's ever grown before and
so that's great it's easy for me to be
like oh I don't look at the numbers yeah
but if the numbers were going down I'd
probably have a lot more existential
crises and journaling sessions with
myself in a coffee shop on my own or for
a walk being like
where's this going yeah everyone do this
is this the beginning of the end yeah if
that's the case then a lot of like
mental gymnastics and cbting myself out
of the concern about that and the fear
of uncertainty and the fear of the
future towards you know what it's fine
um and Lewis hose have actually when you
made connection with recently uh I I
asked him this when I was interviewed on
his podcast like a year and a half ago
and he said that hey look man I've been
in this game for like 10 years and I've
realized it's like a sine wave and
there's some months ago it goes up
another month ago it goes down yeah the
same thing has happened for 10 years so
he's now he said he's now stopped caring
about the sine wave and so I do
sometimes think of that phrase that it's
just a sine wave it's just the way it
goes
I think it changes with Financial
Security too
um you know I think
I think a lot of creators really ride
really ride the roller coaster because
it's that's it for them it's like I'm
living this great life because of this
yeah and if it doesn't go well maybe the
gravy train stops you know like
especially people that were like crypto
creators or like very Niche around one
particular thing that might have been
you know a boom bust cycle and now it's
gone and you're like oh my God all my
sponsors walked out the door all my
because you know they all went bankrupt
or they ran out of money and you realize
that nothing none of this stuff is
permanent yeah and I think that's scary
for a lot of people yeah I think
especially like the Creator I speak to
who's like 80 of their revenue comes
from Brand deals and the other 20 from
AdSense and they're not selling their
own products they're not trying to build
a business around it that's really scary
yeah
um because you're so your lifestyle is
depending on one thing yeah on the whims
of people outside of that are outside of
your control yeah you can't control it
totally yeah yeah sometimes the way I
think about it is like
if I if if I worry about that too much
then it becomes not fun anymore and so
my way of getting around that is
thinking you know what
right now things are good and while
things are good it's it's fine that I
have a team of 13 people that I love
working with because it's great Vibes if
things ever become not good
I mean then we'll just we just downsize
the team yeah like if we try to do it
myself like me plus an assistant and an
editor well that that three-man setup
can literally make probably a million a
year for at least the next 10 years yeah
without too much difficulty if that
doesn't work out even just me great
let's say I lost everything now I'm
doing the Peter levels thing I'm gonna
get back into coding and become an indie
developer and that'll be quite fun it's
like yeah I I tell myself these stories
as a way of kind of hedging against the
inherent uncertainty that's in in a
career like this yeah it's nice to know
that if you had to you could do with
very little yeah it's just like a good
feeling I'm not particularly I'm not a
materialistic person like I'm not into
fancy things I don't have a watch you
know I like wear a whoop in I suppose
I'm like a running watch that I wear
crabby running watch you wear an Apple
Watch I'm not like into cars necessarily
um you know I just don't spend money on
fancy things and my wife is not into
jewelry and you know we don't give each
other jewelry presents like she's not
into bags and fancy clothes and so I
often think about that like if
everything went to like if we were
in the Great Depression 1928 how long
could we just like you know default
alive with things that we have today and
the answer for me at least today is like
literally almost in perpetuity like
businesses could all go to like
everything goes out the door because
we're just not that high cost of a life
and like I know that I can kind of like
hermit if I need to and like do grimy
things I could be a cockroach if I
needed to
um I'm into really nice experiences and
like I like to fly first class when I
fly places and I like to stay in nice
places and I do all those things but I
don't have to do any of that like I
would just not travel or I would just
not do those things and so I do think
it's like Paul Graham had this essay of
like default alive versus default dead
um and he was talking about it in the
context of startups like is your startup
default alive or default dead like if
you were just to stop growing would you
eventually run out of money or not and I
think about that a lot in the context of
my own life like is my life set up in a
way that is default alive if we stop
growing if like the channel stops
growing in your case or if um businesses
stop growing products stop growing
selling you're not doing it anymore
whatever are we gonna be okay like can
we find a way to just like be all right
in perpetuity and if the answer is yes
there's a lot of comfort that's drawn
from that yeah um yeah kind of separate
yourself yeah like I found that when I
sat down and figured out what does my
skeleton crew look like yeah and I
realized that it's a fairly lean team
and if I needed to I could just become a
web developer myself yeah I was like
okay cool now I can enjoy the fruits of
this and not think too hard about like
our head counter or things like that the
um
the idea of one day I think you
mentioned too and alluded to is
something that I found really powerful
in my own life as a system and that's
like
I really struggle with the five and ten
year plans I don't like thinking that
far in advance every time I've tried do
over the course of my life I've been
hilariously wrong and so all I try to do
today is I literally sat down and I
wrote down what are the elements of my
ideal day like what does an ideal day
look like to me and it's not necessarily
specifically like the routines and the
exact time when I do it but it's like
what are the elements of it the core
kind of deconstructed elements and if I
do those things over the course of a day
it was like a beautiful day a perfect
day seven out of seven whatever the
number is and what I've found is that if
I optimize for that having an ideal day
then having another one then having
another one and just stacking together
ideal days I will progress in the
direction that I'm trying to progress in
yeah and it takes so much complexity and
noise out of my entire life and system I
don't have to think about five ten years
I don't think about you know all a
million things if I just have one ideal
day and just focus on that it removes so
much intimidation for me yeah um that
it's it's been really empowering yeah
for me it's it's I've had the same uh
that same feeling except it's an ideal
week so like I literally have my ideal
week on my Google Calendar which is
color coded with like a little like
rainbow colors where and does it sit
alongside your actual calendar so you
know it it is my actual oh it is your
actual calendar good uh in that like
like for example this is what it was
this morning one-on-one with Angus this
morning three and a half hours of book
time whereas team meetings filming block
and then this podcast and dinner because
Tuesday evenings I've earmarked as this
is my default hangout with friends oh
nice so this week we've got this yeah
absolutely next week we've got I've got
for some uni friends coming coming over
for dinner the week after we've got some
more friends coming over for dinner and
then that's also where I force myself to
cook normally except you want to go to
restaurants
because I like fancy experiences
I'm trying to learn how to cook and I
feel like the forcing function of having
friends over encourages me to cook and
it becomes an adventure and all this
kind of stuff
um and I like that ideal week yeah I
like that I mean and it means I can I
can be like okay cool Wednesday evenings
I want to go visit my mom Tuesday
evening someone have friends over
Thursday I want to go kickboxing the gym
three times a week cool yep on a weekend
let's keep that free just because why
not and then I want to do these blocks
of work of deep work in the morning yeah
you actually stick to it how often are
you getting derailed from it
oh like I stick to it 90 of the time
that's great like it's it's been it's
been a challenge over time yeah but
every
one of the real upsides of the whole
team stuff is actually like a couple
weeks ago I was saying to the team you
know guys I feel like yeah things are
just kind of busy I'm not making I I
just I'm not making enough time in the
calendar to like film videos and like
write the book
and one of the members the team was like
it was like but that that why not like
that's literally the thing that we are
all relying on like you filming videos
means that the business does well you're
writing a book means so hopefully the
business does well what's stopping you
yeah I was like you're right and so
we actually did like a group in your
newsletters oh nice yeah a little
whiteboard is like we made like Monday
Tuesday Wednesday and then we were
thinking about it I was like okay right
now like my coaching session with Eric
is like on a Tuesday and that kind of
derails filming on a Tuesday and they're
like I can't just move it to a Wednesday
yeah and I was like that's a great idea
what if what if Wednesdays was all my I
was like but I want to have time I want
to have a calendar where if a cool
person wants to connect over Zoom it's
like I want to be able to talk to them
they were like what about just doing
those on Wednesday afternoon and I was
like oh my God he's so right yeah so now
I have Wednesday afternoons it's like my
calls which I'll take on zoom while
going for a walk around Hyde Park
because why not yeah and when I follow
the ideal week I'm just like life is
great because I've literally decided
what are the elements I want in my life
yeah and they're literally in this week
yeah and if I and it's also great then
because if I want to add something new
I know it needs to fit in the calendar
somehow like I kind of burned myself out
a bit post quitting the job when I was
like I'm going to take singing lessons
three times a week and guitar lessons
three times a week and art less than
three times a week because I really want
to get better at guitar and singing and
art yeah and then after about a week I
was like oh my God like I'm not looking
forward to this anymore etc etc
as now I've decided that like yeah if
there's no space for in the calendar
that means there's no space for it in my
life and it becomes a very easy kind of
by like by virtue of the fact that it's
a calendar you can't overlap things yeah
and so it's just such a nice way of
organizing my time I love that I mean we
make time for the things we care about
and it's never a lack of time it's
always a lack of priorities and so if
something really matters to you you'll
make time in the calendar for it it'll
become a part of your of your ideal week
I do think
that that weak framework is a really
good adaptation of my day I'm gonna I'm
gonna go and sit down and look at it now
I think it's like a good way of a good
way of thinking about it yeah
and being married I'm like I want to see
you on this whole journey yeah because
like even now when I hear you say you
know like three and a half hours on book
and the time filming I'm like man I wish
I could find and maybe I don't wish
because I'm terrible like I have such
bad Focus I can't focus for more than
like an hour on something
um and I'm in the earlier stages of
writing my book where it's quite painful
because I'm not I don't have the like
close enough deadline that I feel the
urgency I mean like abyss of like well
let's do in six months like that's so
far away I'm fine
yeah it's gonna be like two three years
yeah exactly
um which I'm dreading if that's the case
you know I'm just like oh God I can't
have something hanging over my head
um but it is uh I really like the weak
framework that's a good way of thinking
about it so thank you so much this has
been wonderful this has been any any
potting pieces of advice wisdom anything
you would say for the people who have
listened to this far to our two and a
half hour long um
my only piece of parting wisdom because
I think it relates to a lot of things
we've said is
never let your quest for more distract
you from the beauty of enough
oh so I'll end with that never let your
quest for more distract you from the
beauty of enough good stuff thank you so
much thank you all right so that's it
for this week's episode of Deep dive
thank you so much for watching or
listening all the links and resources
that we mentioned in the podcast are
going to be linked down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye